[music playing]
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
After a rough voyage,
we've arrived at the end
of the Tracy Arm Fjord
to search for glacial ice.
Oh my god.
It's so--
GORDON RAMSAY: What a journey.
--gorgeous.
GORDON RAMSAY: It's beautiful.
So we're looking for what size?
So what we want to look for is
something that's very rounded.
GORDON RAMSAY: Right.
What about that one?
That's a--
- No, Gordon.
I don't think that
one's going to work.
That's like your
own private island.
Wow.
Look at that thing.
Let's try this one
here to the left--
the white one at 11:00.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
10,000 years in the making,
these glaciers produce
the purest ice imaginable.
I like that one.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
Perfect for cocktails.
GORDON RAMSAY: So the
secret behind this is--
Screwing.
[laughs]
GORDON RAMSAY: Screwing
these into the big block.
Yes.
And then after that we're
going to hook it up,
and we're going to
hoist it on board.
Got you.
This is the most work I've
ever done [bleep] an ice cube
in my entire life.
- [laughs]
I hope this is going to
make the best cocktail.
It's going to be fabulous.
Just trust me.
GORDON RAMSAY: Right.
You ready?
- Yes.
OK, start screwing.
We're going to hook
it up to a D-ring.
And if it's not all the way in,
it's going to crack the ice.
You have to kind of be,
like, over the water,
you know, so you're
on top of it.
[bleep]
Let's just make sure
they're really down deep.
Are you kidding me, Michelle?
They can't get any
further in there.
OK, let's just test.
Holy [bleep].
Fingers are [bleep] freezing.
See, look.
Yours is coming out.
Mine's coming out?
Yeah.
You've got to get
that in deeper.
Deeper?
Yeah, you're not
all the way in.
When we pull that up on the
winch, it's going to crack.
[bleep]
Perfect.
[winch sounds]
[laughs]
GORDON RAMSAY: Stop.
Stop, stop.
Good job.
[laughter]
That was fun.
GORDON RAMSAY: Amazing.
So you take that
outer layer off.
And then you get to some
of those ice diamonds.
GORDON RAMSAY: Look at this.
Oh, that's gorgeous.
GORDON RAMSAY: That
is so beautiful.
Right?
Look at that formation.
Should we put that in a glass?
Shall we?
You got it in there?
Wow.
Ooh, I like how that--
And what do you think--
throw a little Scotch?
That's a good one.
And now we need a
little vermouth.
I feel like one
of the luckiest
mixologists anywhere
on the planet.
[laughter]
Oh my lord.
Look at that.
Look at the colors.
I think we've earned it.
GORDON RAMSAY: Cheers.
Good health.
- Cheers.
GORDON RAMSAY: Look at that.
What an ice cube.
Oh my lord.
[coughs]
[laughs]
[bleep] That's strong.
I think it's 110 proof.
- [coughs]
- Cheers.
Amazing.
Well done.
I have bars, but I've
never, ever touched an ice
cube that's that perfect.
And it just tasted so clean
and fresh, and slightly
effervescent in a way
that it was almost
lightly sort of carbonated.
And a great way, I think,
to toast the beginning
of this incredible cook,
with an amazing cocktail
laced with glacier ice cubes.
[music playing]